hey hey hey hey how are you so you're
performing tonight because you've won an
Oscar is it easier to come here and you
kind of walk and you're like I know the
drill y'all I'm good when they announce
performing tonight they will probably
preface I'm sure with Oscar winner right
so it's for everybody your date now all
right tell me about cats real quick and
what does it like it with all those
stars on that set it's it's it's like
something really special is being made
and I'm just again happy to be a part of
it I just feel a memory we come down
coming straight it's a live so
everything is gonna live on the set it's
a lot of hard work we're creative as we
go so as
live it in a moment you got the pressure
on that one to doing this on memory
right yes so you feeling that when
you're singing it you gotta go well I
definitely feel the pressure that's why
I couldn't wait to us up with us and I
was just gonna throw a party alone that
the memory and Sun no I have not I
literally have been anticipating doing
that song in the scene since the moment
I got the role like you know is only I
can only mentally prepare and there
wasn't much I could do but literally be
in the who has surprised you who is
surprised you are who who have you seen
that you've been like whoa no and on
cats yeah everything surprises me
because why because it's such it's so
uniquely done and we're all creating
something that does not have a vision to
it so we're learning as we go
we're creating as we go and we're all we
are always surprising ourselves you know
so I feel like
yeah it's like it's a new level from
everyone director from other talent the
dancers and everybody is equally wait I
can't wait
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]